[Music]
which he was Dutch Swedish yeah so is
Ricky's Ricky's Swedish was he yes
originally I thought he was Hungarian I
don't think so no it's a Swedish chapter
an American another famous astronomer
yeah who proposed the existence of
pulsars and neutron stars and yeah and
he's probably the first person to have
observed that there is dark matter in
the universe yes
okay and and what led him to that he was
measuring the speeds of the motions of
galaxies in a huge cluster in toward the
direction of the constellation Coma
Berenices it's called the Coma Cluster
and he was noticing that the galaxies
were moving on average too fast to be
staying together in fact they were
moving relative of each other so quickly
that the gravity of all the galaxies
together would not have held this
cluster of galaxies close instead it
should have scattered apart long ago
cool so he had to fast for the britches
that's what he came down so he said
there's missing mass here for every
galaxy that we see that has a certain
amount of mass hey what's up guys those
guys in the truck saying hello that's
the famous comic so he goes there's mass
missing yes it's missing mass missing
mass and there must because something is
holding the cluster together right yeah
and people said you're nuts but then
over the decades and this is another
process that happened over a long period
of time people other people noticed you
know what there's missing mass elsewhere
too and this became known as the missing
mass problem right in our own galaxy by
the way it's really it's it's not so
much
seeing mass it's too much gravity yet
it's excessive motion yes too much
gravity whether or not it's mass no
you're measuring the gravity right you
got it
you don't have the right to say that
there's something not there right so
over time what happened was the term
missing mass measure the absence of mass
you measured so because yes to be the
amount of mass is what affects the
gravity yes in a traditional traditional
understanding so that so you know it was
called that's called misled
but but over time that terminology was
replaced in part exactly what Neil was
describing instead of calling it
something missing let's call it
something that is there that we don't
see and then for a period of time and
better I would still call it dark
gravity I was about to call it dark
right yeah yeah yeah that are correct
gravity makes sense well but all these
turns make would make good superhero
names wouldn't they
I'm done Oh dark matter I'm missing math